And our next guest takes bargain-hunting
to new heights on TikTok.
And this year alone, she's saved more than $10,000.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Take a look.
(upbeat hip-hop music)
Whoever said nothing in life is free
has clearly never met Kayla.
I have a deal for you.
Coupons with Kayla's TikTok spills all the tea
on scoring the best deals out there.
But if coffee's more your taste,
then there's a deal for that, too.
From clothing and shoes to self-care and food,
Kayla's got the tips for her impressive 2 million followers.
Hosting a dinner party?
Why not get your ingredients for free?
Does someone have new shoes on their wish list?
How about getting them for 50% off?
Wanna get all made up for a date night,
look like a million bucks for only 99 cents?
If frugal fun is what you seek,
then brilliant Kayla is your go-to girl.
And she's here live
(audience applauds)
and in person.
It's Kayla Burk.
Hey, everybody.
(audience cheers)
TikTok superstar.
And your first couponing experience,
the store actually gave you money to leave with the product?
What?
Yeah, I went to the store,
and I went to go get a loofah just to try it out,
and-
I love a loofah.
Yeah, and I gave them a coupon
and they gave me back money,
and I was like, I'm gonna have to start doing this. (laughs)
Okay, so what are some of the biggest items
that you've gotten from couponing?
I've gotten a lot of things on sale.
Just recently, I started a gym in my home
because I got $2,000 worth of gym equipment for $60.
Whoa. How?
Wow.
Coupons.
There was like promo codes online,
and it was just like this one brand
just had a whole bunch of promo codes,
and it just like, the money just kept going down
and down and down.
And I was like, I'll take it. (laughs)
Thank you for doing what you're doing,
sincerely and truly.
(audience applauds)
All right, so we're right here right now.
We've got this awesome table.
Take us through it. You're in the driver's seat.
I'm your passenger. Teach me.
Okay, we'll start with this first section here.
Okay, so this, the first tip we're gonna talk about
is stacking coupons, okay?
So these are things you would find in-store.
So in-store, you have like manufacturer coupons
and you have store coupons.
And there's a lot of stores that will let you use two
of those, one of each on one item.
Really?
So it's like double savings.
And then you can get the coupons on the app.
So if you're going to a store, kinda just download the app,
and there will be a section
where you can get all the coupons super easy.
They make it super convenient.
So when you stack all of them on an item,
it makes it like super cheap.
So for example, if we have some toothpaste,
let's say it's like $5,
and you go on the app and there's a $2 coupon,
and you're like, okay.
But then you go on the ad, the weekly ad,
and they're like, hey, if you buy this item,
we'll give you $3 in points.
And then, so the $2 coupon, the $3 in points,
that's now free, 100% free.
But my favorite, (laughs)
(audience applauds)
my absolute favorite thing to buy are money makers.
An example would be like these razors.
So let's say, let's get specific,
like $6.29 for these razors.
Uh-huh.
And you go on the app and there's a $5 coupon,
so that makes it super cheap.
You're like, $1.29? That's great.
But then you look in the ad, and let's say, they also say,
"Hey, buy this item, we'll give you $3 in points,"
so you-
So you've made money now.
Yeah, 'cause you're paying $1.29,
but they're giving you $3, so that's more than you paid.
And then you like just accumulate those points.
And I use those extra points that they give me-
Yeah.
To buy other things that I need
that are kinda hard to get on sale.
So like toilet paper is a great example.
You can get it like 50% off every now and then,
but it's really hard to get for free.
Mm-hmm.
So what I like to do is I like to use
that free money type stuff that they're giving us
and use it on items like that
to get it super cheap, super free.
So that's the breakdown.
Amazing.
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
Amazing.
Okay, what is this plate of pastries?
Okay, so I love this.
This is, the second tip is birthdays.
There are so many things you can get for free
on your birthday.
Really?
Like so much stuff.
What you wanna do is you wanna sign up for emails
for different companies,
and then either like the day of your birthday
or like the beginning of the month,
so like my birthday's May 19th,
so May 1st, I'll start getting emails saying,
"Hey, it's your birthday month.
Here's $10 to spend in our store,"
or, "Here's a 30% off coupon anything that month."
But then the pastries and stuff are here
because the other thing you can get free all day is food.
All day, from the time you wake up
to the time you go to sleep, free food all day long.
Really?
Yeah, 'cause they'll send you emails and stuff.
And so like on my birthday last year,
I started the day off with coffee.
I got a free coffee.
And then there are places
where you can get pastries, donuts.
I know like a stack of pancakes, so like breakfast.
Mm-hmm.
I know there's places that give like free wings,
free sandwiches, so there's like lunch, dinner.
And then the amount of places that give you dessert,
like brownies, ice cream, there's so many.
And so you just sign up for their emails,
and they'll send it to you, and then you,
if you are hungry by the end of the day on your birthday,
there's a problem.
You did something wrong.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience applauds)
I love that, Kayla.
Yeah.
What's your third tip?
Okay, the third one is online stuff.
You want to follow companies on social media
because sometimes they'll post either like flash deals
or coupons, stuff like that.
My favorite one that has happened recently,
people don't even believe me when I say it,
is there is a company who would give a 99% off coupon
up to like a certain amount.
And so this year, I got my boyfriend a sweater,
and it was originally $30.
It ended up being 30 cents for the sweater
because of the coupon.
But you wouldn't have known that it was happening
unless you were following them on social media.
So that's why it's like super important to do that.
Okay.
And then, also, signing up for emails are so important
for coupons because like, okay, so you have like cute.
Oh, those are so cute.
Cute little pictures.
These are my doggies.
Those are so adorable.
That's Douglas and Lucy right there.
Ah.
But you can get prints like that all the time.
Every month, I'm getting free prints
because I'll get an email, and they'll say,
"Hey, here's a coupon code.
Go online, type it in,
and then order it, and it'll be free."
So some people think it's really hard to coupon
and whatnot.
Yeah.
So it can be intimidating, but there are rebate apps
that you can get that you go on your phone
and you go to the store and you just take a receipt,
take a picture, and it'll give you points.
There's a couple of them that I like.
There's Shopkick and Fetch Rewards.
And basically, all you do is for Shopkick,
it'll tell you a bunch of different items.
And they'll say, "Hey, go to this store, buy this item,
and then show us a picture of your receipt proving
that you bought it, and we'll give you points."
And then those points, you just get gift cards.
And then Fetch Rewards is the same.
Just everything I'm buying just turns into the gift cards.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, I just think
that you are such a game changer.
And I'm so glad that you're out there
kind of laying the breadcrumbs
so that other people can partake
in all of the hard work-
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
That you're doing.
Oh, yeah.
You're lighting the way.
Thank you, Kayla Burk. I so appreciate it.
(upbeat pop music)